oh gaston what's the wi-fi i can't no i
can't get in
oh it's arg
connect your teams easier than
connecting your wi-fi hubspot grow
better all hands on deck
what's up it's shawn and it is one
question friday so we are taking one
listener question and answering it on
the spot hopefully five minutes maybe 10
minutes let's see how this goes i'm
gonna play this audio recording that ben
sent to me i haven't heard it yet let's
hear it together
so i was having a cola the other day and
i was thinking about this question
what do you do differently that allowed
you to succeed that you think other
people who had similar circumstances to
you did not where did you succeed where
they did not
okay
uh good question a very broad question
right so we could take this a bunch of
different ways here's how i want to take
it
what are the common answers that you
think people would give to a question
like this so oh what do you do
differently that helps you succeed well
some people will say
let's break it into groups there's the
um overly humble the overly humble will
say you know
all credit to god uh i've been blessed i
was really lucky and you know i just
kind of
kept putting one foot in front of the
other and worked hard and and i uh you
know i'm just fortunate to be born in
this great place with all my my limbs
and my brain and all this right okay
there's that path
all true things but not that useful to
somebody listening so let's let's kick
that out
also
that applies to many other people who
didn't have the same result as you so
that certainly couldn't be it okay
second thing hard work right hard work
is the next thing that people love to
say i think because
hard work feels like you earned it
and it feels like you're not saying
you're better than everybody else it
feels like you made better choices than
others that were available to them too
and
who can argue with hard work but the
reality is i really don't work very hard
um or at least i don't feel that way
the thing i would say is i actually do
work a lot
but
i only work on stuff i like and so i
think hard workers you know like a
janitor works hard a line cook works
hard you know um a single mother works
hard you know and so i don't really put
what i do has you know
pretty much no physical strain
no emotional strength a small emotional
strain i guess
and um
you know honestly it's fun like i do it
because i enjoy it i'm not doing it
because i kind of feel like i have to do
this in order to get what i want that is
not at all how i think about things and
if there are many areas where i'm like
oh man if i worked harder i'd get a
better result i can't bring myself to do
it i'm lazy in that way uh the reason i
work a bunch is because i really uh like
feels like play to me it's like watching
somebody play a video game
you don't have to tell them hey sit down
and focus on this for three hours like
what are you talking about this call of
duty of course i'll play this as long as
i can
and so
it's not hard work so what is it then
well you said something in your question
which was
what's different about you than like
what what did you do differently than
like others like you and similar
situations to you okay that's a good way
of asking the question
let's take my college right here i'm
wearing the shirt i went to duke
and there's a bunch of super smart
people who went to duke in fact that
duke i was a very mediocre student um
middle of the pack maybe slightly below
average
and um
you know whatever it's a good school a
lot of smart people a lot of hard
workers okay i do think that i've had
probably more success you know by kind
of a traditional definition but also
just more fun
than 99 of the other people who
graduated in my class
i could be wrong no way to really know
but
i believe that to be true from from what
i've seen so what is different what i
would say is that most of my friends
from college most of the people i went
to school with
played it quote unquote
safe
and is it really safe
uh that's the question
and because to me safe is good
if you can get the outcome you want with
the least risk possible safe is awesome
right like i don't want to you know go
to war because the outcome i want is to
be alive and like i can just stay at
home and that is way less risk than um
going to war
but i also don't just stay at home and
not drive places because i want to go
see them i want to go to a movie or i
want to go to the grocery store whatever
i have an outcome i want but i'll take
the least risk possible i'm not going to
you know drive a motorcycle i'll drive a
car you get the idea so to me
safety is when you get the outcome you
want with the least risk
taken
what i saw was most of my friends from
college
took what was what you would call a safe
path
if you wanted that outcome
the reality is that i definitely did not
want the outcome that those jobs led to
so the jobs the most popular tracks were
doctor
um
kind of like lawyer
consultant or banker those are like the
kind of like high achiever paths that i
would say most
of the smart smartest people in um
at my school did
and i guess the other one would be like
corporate manager of some kind okay cool
so
the problem with that is when i look at
what success looks like for a doctor for
a lawyer
for a consultant for a banker or for a
corporate manager
none of those
by default would get me the outcome i
wanted right i was like dude i want to
make tons of money
i want to have fun every day i want to
have action creativity i don't want to
just be doing the same thing over and
over right like i shadowed a doctor
because i was pre-med i took the mcats i
was planning to go to med school until i
shadowed a doctor
and i went to shadow him to figure out
uh can i do this but by the end of it
the answer i walked away with was i
don't want to do this because it was
extremely repetitive what was happening
every day
and
you're helping people which is awesome
but i could not stand the repetitive
nature of seeing patients and having the
same you know as an orthopedic guy oh
yep you have torn meniscus you have a
torn ligament you have joint pain and
there's nothing we could do for you
that's what it was over and over and
over again
and so um i didn't want the winning path
of that
um
so financially some some paths i was
like oh man you work how hard and you
make how much and like
is there a path here where i could have
like i don't know 50 million dollars
like what if i want 50 million dollars
right you don't have to want it
but let's say i do want it because i do
right and i'm not afraid to say it i'm
not ashamed of the things i wanted i was
like that sounds awesome if i could
choose between less money and more money
i'm choosing more money right that was
very obvious to me at the time and when
i looked at how much you could make in a
certain amount of time the first let's
say 10 years of your career i was like
wow
okay finance i might be able to get
there but not really these other paths
okay maybe i can do it in finance or
consulting but what do i have to do to
get there oh man i gotta grind 80 90
hours a week kind of as the low man on
the totem pole and i'm just like an
excel monkey and i'm like you know i'm
not building i'm not creating anything
new and i'm not building my own business
i'm like just this kind of like
middleman uh that's what it felt like
or corporate management that's cool but
like i got to go to an office every day
nine to five wear a certain thing and
talk a certain way and spend a bunch of
my days doing um you know like you know
certain meetings that i didn't want to
do like you know talent calibration and
like you know employee onboarding and
all this [__] right so i didn't find
that fun
and i even saw people who were playing
that game at a high level so for example
when we got acquired by twitch i saw
well what does the ceo of a
multi-billion dollar company do every
day and what does you know the vp of
product do and what does the cto do what
do these people do every day if i look
at their day
and i don't want it then why am i in
this track so i would say the fir the
most important thing i did differently
was get clear on what i actually wanted
how i wanted my life to go
and then i looked at the quote unquote
safe tracks and i realized pretty
quickly that those don't get me to that
thing i want so in that sense they're
not safe at all they're extremely
dangerous to my goals right are you
following that like if you
if you look at what you want if you have
a clear picture of what you want
and then you look at the safe path and
you say does the safe path get me to
what i want and the answer is no then it
is not safe it is extremely risky
because it's putting my dream at risk
and um knowing what you want also takes
a little bit of work
so take some time take some imagining
take some sampling i would go and meet a
bunch of people and be like so what's
your life like you know uh okay you have
this much money how does that work you
have this uh work schedule how does that
work oh you never see your kids okay
that doesn't sound like a win right like
uh my buddy dated a girl in college my
roommate was dating a girl in college
and her dad was a high you know whatever
partner at
whatever deloitte boston consulting
whatever whatever it was
and you know she was just like yeah
growing up like he was home thursday
through sunday and then he would fly out
thursday through saturday he'd fly out
sunday and he'd be at a client site from
you know sunday through thursday every
week and they fly back and he was super
tired and that was the first 18 years of
my life so i immediately could cross
that safe path of consulting off because
if that's how the the top of the top do
it in that field then i don't want to do
it and of course there are outliers in
every
in every industry every track there are
some outliers
but then i'd have to be really clear
that hey am i betting on being an
outlier in that path if so then
i got to be willing to make that choice
so for example i chose entrepreneurship
what i knew was that the day-to-day of
an entrepreneur sounded really fun i get
to build a product create a product from
scratch maybe invent a new product um i
get to sell it that sounds interesting
marketing i always found fun and
you know i get to go on this ride where
i'm sometimes i'm pitching to investors
sometimes customers sometimes i'm
putting out a fire over here that
sounded really fun to me i tried it out
and i actually really enjoyed it and i
knew that okay most entrepreneurs don't
make it but i thought well if i really
enjoy this
then i'm probably going to be willing to
do it for 10 15 years and what i saw was
that
most people would quote these statistics
that ninety percent of businesses fail
or that this individual idea has a very
low chance of having a very low chance
of success and that is true most
individual ideas and businesses do fail
and the way uh the quote i heard was
that yes startups fail but entrepreneurs
don't what that means is that
if you look at any great entrepreneur
any entrepreneur who sticks with it
who's really tries hard and actually has
some skill
over a 10 to 15 year period they all win
right they tend to they tend to win mo
the odds are in their favor that in a 10
to 15 year period they do have a win and
when they win they win in an order of
magnitude of millions and millions of
dollars okay great
so
even though one idea that i'm doing this
year might not have the highest odds of
success if i just keep at this for 10 15
years my odds of success go from
individually very low to collectively
over 10 50 years very high so i love
that
i love the size of the prize i love the
likelihood of success and i love the day
to day to get there which told me i'll
probably stick with it long enough to
hit a win
and so that's how i chose what i wanted
to do so in summary
what i think i did differently was get
clear on what i wanted
and then i what i recognized was that
the quote unquote safe paths weren't
really so safe after all
because they had a very low chance of
getting me to that outcome that i wanted
and so in that sense they were the
riskiest paths of all whereas most
people i think gravitated towards
something that sounded good in theory or
sounded good to their parents or sounded
good to their aunts and uncles and their
peers and their teachers and whoever and
they said yep this this sounds good and
they got onto a track that actually
won't lead them to a lifestyle that they
want whereas i figured out the lifestyle
i wanted first and then i figured out
and then i looked at what tracks can get
me there and i chose the safest amongst
those
all right that's all hope that was
helpful
come on i know that was helpful it had
to be helpful right i put my put my
heart into that one so i hope that it
was helpful i hope i might have took an
idea that you already had and maybe put
it a little differently or brought it to
the front of your mind and maybe it was
buried in the back of your mind that's
that's a win for me out of these so one
question friday in the books
[Music]
you